es el duelo entre el gran favorito y una
de las sensaciones del torneo que cierra
los cuartos de final senegal él lleva
toda la presión frente a esta
sorprendente guinea ecuatorial que ha
superado las expectativas al meterse
entre los ocho mejores del torneo por el
lado de los leones de teranga sadio man
es su gran figura el delantero del
liverpool no ha sufrido inconvenientes
después del golpe en la cabeza que lo
obligó a salir frente a cabo verde y
será titular
además smile azar finalmente el liberado
por el watford se ha sumado al plantel
pero el seleccionador senegalés se alió
si se advirtió que no será un partido
sencillo para su equipo porque en frente
está esta línea ecuatorial que en su
camino a los cuartos de final ha tumbado
a argelia y amal y los dirigidos por
juan michel se han fortalecido en su
solidez defensiva que le ha permitido
solamente recibir un gol en lo que va
del torneo buscará en guinea ecuatorial
llegar a una semifinal de copa africana
por segunda vez en su historia e
interesante duelo el que tendremos en el
amadou ahidjo y espera y observa
atentamente burkina faso que será el
rival de quien resulte vencedor en este
encuentro